guerre au Mali coulisse d'un engrenage
documentaire réalisé par Jean crépu
avant tout vous venez de le voir
l'histoire d'un échec celui d'un état
malien gangrené de longue date par la
corruption et de la communauté
internationale ou la France a figuré en
première ligne qui aura jusqu'au bout
chercher à le soutenir les militaires
français ont donc désormais quitté le
Mali et le Burkina Faso dès lors quel
rôle peut encore jouer la France au
Sahel au nom de la lutte contre le
djihadisme et bien nous allons en
débattre maintenant avec nos invités
présents sur ce plateau de débat doc en
commençant par vous il y a galéré
Bakayoko bienvenue vous êtes politologue
présidente de l'Africain de Security
Network spécialiste des politiques
internationales de sécurité et de
réforme des systèmes de sécurité en
Afrique de l'Ouest Rémy carriol est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste indépendant avec ces
dernières années la publication de
plusieurs enquêtes et reportages sur le
continent africain et notamment bien sûr
au Sahel vous coordonnez le comité
éditorial du site d'information Afrique
21 et votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule
Le Mirage saélien la France en guerre en
Afrique Serval barkhane et après point
d'interrogation ça tombe bien c'est le
sujet de cette émission c'est un livre
publié aux éditions La Découverte et
puis enfin avec nous Bruno Fouks
bienvenue à vous vous êtes un ancien
journaliste aujourd'hui député MoDem du
Haut-Rhin bon connaisseur de l'Afrique
vous aussi et depuis peu secrétaire
général de l'Assemblée parlementaire de
la Francophonie vous venez de lancer une
mission parlementaire à propos je cite
de la stratégie française en Afrique la
France est devenue une puissance comme
une autre en Afrique elle suscite même
de l'hostilité dans certains pays
l'objectif de cette mission et de mettre
en lumière les raisons pour lesquelles
la France a perdu une part de son
influence en Afrique dites-vous à nos
confrères des dernières nouvelles d'Al
c'était le 19 mars dernier à quelle date
votre mission va-t-elle rendre ses
conclusions lorsque un monsieur qui est
très vaste il faut consulter beaucoup de
d'experts dans beaucoup de domaines donc
on pense que d'ici le mois de septembre
on aura fait un travail suffisant pour
d'une part analyser un certain nombre
d'éléments mais surtout faire des
propositions pour voir comment
effectivement on peut restaurer une
posture et donc une influence qui
correspond plus à la situation de la
France et à ses ambitions rendez-vous
donc en septembre prochain pour les
conclusions de cette mission que vous
êtes en train de lancer ici à
l'Assemblée nationale on va resituer si
vous voulez bien le Mali c'était l'objet
du documentaire que nous venons de voir
le Mali avec ses 21 millions
d'habitants cinq fois le territoire de
de la France et ces pays frontaliers que
voyaient apparaître sur cette carte
l'Algérie avec une frontière de 1300 km
communes avec le Mali le Niger le
Burkina Faso la Mauritanie qui faisait
partie du fameux
le G5 Sahel qui a travaillé justement
sur une reconstruction possible du côté
du Sahel 10 ans après l'intervention
française il y a à la menace djihadiste
est toujours là elle est plus que jamais
présente au sel on l'a vu dans ce
documentaire et c'est vrai la démocratie
est devenue un souvenir maintenant au
Mali on peut parler d'un échec de cette
séquence de 10 années où laquelle ou la
France est a été pour le moins présente
notamment avec l'opération barkhane on
peut dire les choses comme ça
aujourd'hui très clairement c'est un
échec très difficile
de qualifier d'autres choses que d'échec
cette intervention de la communauté
internationale en général parce que la
situation de la mission des Nations
Unies du G5 Sahel qu'il n'est plus
aujourd'hui composé que de quatre états
de l'intervention de l'Union européenne
ce sont révélés tout aussi impuissante
que l'opération barkhane a enrayé
l'enracinement des
mais aussi leur expansion puisque
aujourd'hui ils sont présents au-delà de
la zone saélienne elle-même et sont
également actifs dans le septentrion des
pays du Golfe de Guinée notamment le
Togo le Bénin le Ghana la Côte d'Ivoire
l'objectif de guerre si on peut dire des
choses comme ça c'était la lutte contre
le djihadisme est-ce que c'était contre
le terrorisme et ce terme est important
à mon avis parce que il explique aussi
l'échec que l'on a rencontré parce que
on ne combat pas un mode opérationnel le
terrorisme c'est une façon de combattre
et utiliser ce qualificatif revient à
des politiser l'adversaire or ce à quoi
on s'est heurté au Sahel c'est tout
d'abord à des groupes djihadistes qui
s'opposaient les uns aux autres et qui
ne pouvaient donc pas être
considérer comme une catégorie
globalisante donc en l'occurrence les
groupes affiliés Al-Qaïda et ce affiliés
à l'état islamique et d'autre part ces
groupes avaient un véritable agenda
politique en termes de forme de l'État
en termes d'Administration de la justice
de modèles éducatifs auxquels la seule
réponse qui a été apportée par les États
sahéliens et par leur partenaire à
commencer par la France était celui de
la restauration de l'autorité de l'État
or cet état comme le monde très bien le
documentaire était un état beaucoup plus
prédateur que protecteur dans ce
documentaire il nous est dit
qu'aujourd'hui l'Islam a investi
pleinement investi le champ politique au
malice c'est réellement le cas
aujourd'hui c'est le constat que vous
faites aujourd'hui selon les
informations dont vous disposez oui mais
ça ne date pas vraiment d'hier en fait
parce que l'islam politique est une
force qui
imprègne la société malienne depuis de
nombreuses années avant même le
déclenchement de l'opération Serval
avant même que les groupes djihadistes
ne s'emparent d'une partie du nord du
pays en fait il y avait déjà cette qui a
existé sauf que effectivement depuis
quelques années elle a pris du poids
elle a pris de l'importance mais ce ne
le résultat finalement d'un travail de
SAP mené en profondeur par des
organisations islamiques financé par
l'extérieur mais qui ont un vrai
un vrai pouvoir d'influence au niveau du
Mali et qui petit à petit sont en train
quelque part d'imposer leur point de vue
et leur modèle de gouvernance parce que
au-delà de l'islam de l'islamisme armé
qui est illustré interprété par les
groupes djihadistes dont on parle ici il
y a des groupes en islam politique qui
prend la forme de partie qui se réclame
de cette islamisme là mais qui prend la
forme aussi de figure et notamment de
notables et d'imam religieux qui ont un
vrai impact sur la population malienne
on a vu l'imam dico dans ce documentaire
qui prêche le web
par exemple Bruno Fuchs même constat
aujourd'hui vous parlez d'un échec quand
on voit la fin de la mission barkhane
oui c'est un échec je crois personne ne
peut dire l'inverse quand on regarde la
réalisation de ce que barkhane a fait
pendant 9 ans il y a quand même beaucoup
il y a eu des des succès c'est une
mission qui a servi à combattre
l'avancée et une grande partie justement
des tentatives d'attaque terroristes on
voit un officier militaire dans ce
documentaire qui dit il y a eu deux
portes de sortie il y a un moment dans
cette histoire la première c'était la
fin de l'opération Serval où les
militaires français aurait pu se retirer
considérant que mission avait été
accomplie et la deuxième porte de sortie
ça aurait pu être l'élection d'un
nouveau président et le maintien de la
démocratie bien entendu et l'élection
d'un président qu'on a vu une amende
dans ce documentaire à la tête du pays
on a pris une ni l'une ni l'autre est-ce
que ça a été ça l'erreur fondamentale
sur le plan militaire parce que c'est
l'analyse pas de l'objectif de barkhane
Castres qui est dans ce reportage piloté
l'opération Serval et il a souhaité que
barkhane change de nom et soit pas la
suite de Serval pense en déjà que pour
sanctuariser la réussite de Serval il a
voulu donner un autre nom à barcarne
pensant déjà que d'embarcades il y avait
les germes d'une fin annoncée la
difficulté c'est qu'il y avait pas de
stratégie d'embarca on voit bien et vous
l'avez bien dit que l'objectif c'est de
combattre le terrorisme et d'accompagner
les états or en cama accompagne pas les
états avec
3000 4000 5000 hommes uniquement des
militaires qui eux sont en opération
militaire donc un je pense qu'il a
manqué si on pouvait faire l'analyse il
a manqué d'objectifs stratégiques et de
d'accompagner d'accompagnement de l'état
des services publics donc en plus de
l'armée il aurait fallu certainement
accompagner les États à restaurer
votre service public et à saturer
sécuriser les zones que l'on avait
permis de reconquérir parce qu'il y a eu
des reconquêtes voilà et après sur les
détails il y a eu d'autres éléments pour
analyser
l'échec mais principalement l'opération
c'est pas un échec militaire il est
plutôt c'est plutôt un échec stratégique
et politique on va voir un extrait du
documentaire il s'agit de
Abdoulaye Diop qui est le ministre des
Affaires étrangères du Mali et qui
s'exprimait devant l'Assemblée générale
de l'ONU
chaque fois que le Mali a été dans des
situations difficiles depuis notre
indépendance la Russie a toujours été
avec nous aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
une situation difficile et nous nous
tournons encore vers cet ami pour qu'il
puisse nous aider à sortir
le Mali et la Russie renouent leurs
liens historiques pour sceller un
partenariat militaire qui signe un
nouvel alliance alors il s'est aussi
exprimé devant l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU c'est pas l'extrait que nous
venons de voir mais les propos sont à
peu près les mêmes et il s'agit
évidemment de ce fameux retournement
d'alliance auquel on a assisté à la fin
de l'année 2021 au profit de la Russie
on a vu la broche le ministre des
Affaires étrangères à l'instant sur ces
images de Russie
c'est peut-être ça l'échec le plus
important c'est que non seulement c'est
retiré mais mais sont les Russes ont
pris la place via cette fameux
mercenaires Wagner
donc il faudra tout de même nous
expliquer ce qu'ils vont faire sur le
terrain concrètement parce que ils ont
pas le même objectif que ce qui était
l'objectif des militaires français alors
plusieurs éléments d'abord moi à mon
avis contrairement une idée reçue la
parenthèse c'est l'accueil qui a été
réservée à la France en 2013
historiquement depuis les indépendances
le Mali a toujours été extrêmement
proche de l'Union soviétique des ex
Républiques Socialistes et il y a eu une
parenthèse à la faveur de la chute du
mur de Berlin qui s'est d'ailleurs
accompagné de la chute du dictateur
militaire malien mais y compris
et il faut avoir conscience du fait que
tout d'abord les présidents
démocratiquement élus qui ont été chacun
renversés par des tas militaires
eux-mêmes avaient conclu des accords de
coopération notamment en matière de
vente d'armement avec la Russie bien
avant c'est arrivé de Wagner et d'autre
part il faut aussi se rendre compte
qu'il y a de très grands très grand
nombre de Maliens qui sont russophones
qui ont fait leurs études soit dans les
académies militaires soit dans les
universités russes donc il y a
je vous ai déjà un environnement
favorable la Russie n'est pas arrivée
comme ça du jour au lendemain au Mali
pour ce qui concerne le rôle de Wagner
donc qui à mon avis est très
improprement qualifiée de société
mercenaires par qu'il s'agit en réalité
d'un sous-traitant de l'État russe dont
les liens et le statut juridique sont
extrêmement difficiles à cerner mais qui
est beaucoup plus présent que dans la
seule sphère militaire moi je ne pense
pas que les objectifs de Wagner en tout
cas ceux qui lui sont fixés par le
gouvernement malien qui il faut le dire
n'a jamais reconnu contrairement au
président Poutine et sergueil lavrof la
présence de Wagner les objectifs restent
totalement militaires c'est-à-dire de
détruire de neutraliser cet adversaire
djihadiste et il n'a ni parviennent pas
plus que les Français en revanche s'ils
sont extrêmement efficaces dans le champ
de la guerre informationnelle où ils
sont tout à fait capables de déployer
des stratégies absolument redoutable
Wagner c'est un groupe de mercenaires
criminels l'assurance vie des régimes
défaillants et des puccistes avec des
comportements de prédation sur les mines
les ressources premières voire de
violence sur les populations viols et
autres voilà comment définissez Wagner
Emmanuel Macron c'était le 27 février
dernier à l'occasion d'une de
l'exposition de sa nouvelle stratégie
pour l'Afrique on va y revenir dans un
instant qui est venu chercher Wagner au
Mali pourquoi appelle-t-on Wagner à la
rescousse est-ce bien pour lutter contre
le terrorisme djihadiste ou ont-ils
d'autres préoccupations
avec un comportement de prédateur par
exemple oui alors ce qu'on dit c'est
assez difficile de déterminer finalement
quelle est la tente du pouvoir malien
parce que tout est opaque dans cette
affaire évidemment
le discours est de dire la France est
partie on le remplace par Wagner pour
nous aider à lutter contre le groupe il
y a probablement aussi une volonté
d'assurer propre sécurité l'assurance
vie dans Emmanuel Macron a parlé petite
parenthèse la France a parfois été aussi
l'assurance vie de certains dictateurs
et elle est encore aujourd'hui notamment
je pense au chat c'est autre chose voilà
mais en tout cas c'est quand même
difficile parce que tout est opaque dans
cette collaboration ce qui est quand
même comment expliquer que comment on
parle d'un milieu de soldats Wagner sur
le terrain au Mali il y en a également
au burguina Faso semble-t-il comment un
millier de soldats pourrait faire mieux
que les 5000 soldats français au Mali
oui bon de toute manière au vu de ce qui
est fait sur le terrain depuis que
Walner et sur le terrain c'est-à-dire un
peu plus d'un an désormais on voit bien
qu'il n'y a pas de résultats sur le plan
opérationnel militaire par contre comme
il y a y aller la bien évoqué il y a un
gros travail qui est mené sur le plan de
la perception de du champ informationnel
et là il faut reconnaître que Wagner est
assez redoutable parce que dans ce qu'on
a appelé le sentiment anti français même
si cette ce phénomène a des causes très
profondes et touche également à
l'histoire entre la France et ses
anciennes colonies il faut reconnaître
que le groupe Wagner et c'est une
zinatrol ont joué un rôle assez
important au niveau notamment des
réseaux sociaux le Mali comme d'ailleurs
le Burkina Faso finalement
des noms l'abandon l'État français pour
justifier ce renversement d'alliance oui
alors il y a plusieurs éléments le
premier c'est qu'on simplifie le débat
en disant Wagner ou la France la Russie
et la France il y a quand même sur place
l'Union européenne il y a 14000 soldats
ou policiers de la minusma donc le débat
il se limite pas non plus à cette
médiatiquement qu'on limite à ce
ministre sont les forces de l'ONU de
l'ONU et il y a quand même 4 fois plus
de soldats de l'ONU que de force
française au plus haut de la force
barkhane donc la situation est pas aussi
simple que ça sur Wagner donc vous avez
dit mille soldats sont les chiffres qui
circulent maintenant de toute façon
c'est très opaque comme vous venez de le
dire mais on voit bien que que ces
soldats sont plutôt là pour essayer de
sécuriser la jungle et le pouvoir en
place que pour faire des opérations
militaires de grande envergure peut-être
dans deux ou trois zones précises mais
peuvent pas aller beaucoup plus loin et
on voit que la question qui celle qu'on
a évoqué tout à l'heure de la résolution
politique n'est pas plus abordée
maintenant qu'elle ne l'était avant la
résolution on peut pas dire en Ukraine
que la résolution va être politique à la
fin et pas imaginer que ça elle la
raison sera politique et je pense qu'une
des erreurs si on veut revenir ces
heures de conception que la France a pu
commettre c'est que on a pensé que la
résolution de ce conflit pouvait être
militaire et à un moment quand Jean-Yves
Le Drian dit on ne peut pas négocier
avec les terroristes il a raison d'un
point de vue conceptuel pense que la
résolution du Mali on le verra ne peut
être que politique et donc ne peut être
avancer que lorsque l'on a commencé à
discuter pas avec les groupes
djihadistes les deux groupes acné et
l'État islamique mais avec une grande
partie de la terreur locale ou de
l'insécurité locale qui sont provoquées
par des questions purement ethniques et
non pas par des questions idéologiques
ou islamiques oui j'abende complètement
et à mon sens c'est la grande erreur qui
a commis le gouvernement français sur
ces dernières années puisque assez
rapidement à partir de 2016-2017 au Mali
un certain nombre de personnes des
notables des responsables religieux des
responsables politiques émettent
l'hypothèse d'entamer des discussions
avec certains des chefs de ces groupes
djihadistes ils disent finalement est-ce
qu'on peut pas trouver un terrain
d'entente plutôt que de continuer cette
guerre qui n'arrive à rien et qui fait
des milliers de morts et immédiatement à
ce moment-là la France a imposé son veto
parce qu'à l'époque on est notamment je
me souviens en 2017 à la France a un
pouvoir important sur le sur le régime
malien elle a un pouvoir d'influence du
fait que elle a quand même des soldats
qui se battent dans ce pays et Jean-Marc
Ayros fait le déplacement en tant que le
ministre des Affaires étrangères à
Bamako et 5 jours après que autour d'une
conférence nationale l'une des
conclusions a été de dire il faut
peut-être entamer des discussions cinq
jours après Jean-Marc ayraudy hors de
question et ça c'est renouvelé à
plusieurs reprises en fait et ça c'est
la principale erreur des autorités
françaises c'est d'avoir un voulu donner
le prix humain à la force militaire dans
un conflit qui serait de Laura forcément
par de toute manière une discussion et
de d'avoir voulu aussi imposer ces vues
et sa conception de ce conflit alors
qu'il évoluait au Mali mais aussi au
Niger et au Burkina Faso cette
inflexibilité de la France sur cette
question du dialogue avec les groupes
djihadistes n'est plus de mise
aujourd'hui notamment au Niger ou un
grand nombre de forces de la force
ont été redéployées environ 1500 hommes
en dans un contexte où le président
Bazoum assume publiquement de dialoguer
non seulement avec des responsables
d'Al-Qaïda qui sont généralement perçus
comme beaucoup plus ouverts au dialogue
mais également avec des représentants de
l'État islamique et aujourd'hui on voit
très bien que l'option
diplomatique
adoptée par les autorités africaines ne
peut plus être mise à mal par le véto
français c'est une évolution majeure à
mon avis alors les résultats sont pour
l'instant très très limités dans la
négociation au Niger c'est très très
limité comme résultat mais ça veut dire
que en parallèle de la force militaire
il faut avoir une approche stratégique
et politique bien évidemment alors je
l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure le 27 février
dernier est dans le contexte dont nous
avons parlé juste avant et le contexte
évoqué évidemment dans le film que nous
avons vu ensemble le chef de l'État
Emmanuel Macron a redéfini une nouvelle
stratégie diplomatique immunitaire pour
l'Afrique avec deux mots clés
co-construction et humidité alors sur le
plan militaire la logique et que notre
modèle ne doit plus être basé sur des
bases militaires comme celles que nous
avons aujourd'hui demain notre présence
militaire s'inscrira dans le cadre de
base d'école d'académie qui seront gérés
conjointement cette transformation va
commencer dans les mois qui viennent sur
le principe de la co-construction avec
une diminution visible de nos troupes et
en même temps une augmentation de nos
partenaires africains sur ces bases donc
nous allons rester
en Afrique nos militaires vont rester en
Afrique redéploiement vous l'avez dit
mais on s'interrogeait sur le fait qu'on
que nous troupes reste ou pas dans cette
zone la réponse est oui selon le chef de
l'État et selon cette nouvelle stratégie
et vous avez été amené à réagir
immédiatement après cette intervention
du chef de l'État en disant finalement
rien change pourquoi rien ne change avec
cette nouvelle stratégie selon vous
alors rien ne change tout d'abord parce
qu'à mon avis cette nouvelle stratégie
n'est toujours pas définie on voit très
bien et d'ailleurs on nous a de nouveau
indiqué qu'il faudrait encore environ 6
mois pour avoir une idée très précise
des contours du dispositif mais ce que
le président de la République a indiqué
à savoir ces fameuses académies co-gérés
existe déjà et existe depuis 1998 ça
s'appelle les écoles nationales à
vocation régionale ce sont des
établissements cogérés par la France par
les autorités du pays haute qui
accueille des stagiaires non pas
seulement du pays lui-même mais
également de la sous-région ou du
continent dans son ensemble donc il n'y
a absolument pas d'innovation dans ce
nouveau de ce qui est présenté comme un
nouveau concept ni dans son contenu de
manière beaucoup plus préoccupante parce
que on critique beaucoup l'intervention
barkhane en elle-même et on s'interroge
peu sur de la coopération de défense qui
elle aussi a démontrer toutes ses
limites parce que le recours à la
formation qui apparaît comme la solution
toujours promu par les partenaires
extérieurs à démontré qu'elle ne
correspondait pas au type d'ennemis que
l'on combattait les approches
doctrinales opérationnelles enseignée
par l'armée française et par les autres
partenaires sont incapables de faire
face au type de conflictualité que l'on
rencontre aujourd'hui au Sahel alors
point de vue parce que effectivement
c'est peut-être un des éléments positifs
entre guillemets de la fin de barcades
c'est la France est réinterroger sur la
doctrine à mettre en place et j'étais
obligé moi il y a trois semaines il y a
au Niger des soldats français ils sont
sous commandement nigériens et ils sont
sous stratégie se lit nigériens qui
décide de la stratégie et qui décide des
opérations et donc quand ils sont des
Français ils appellent les Français il y
a une échange d'informations ce qui
était ni le cas au Mali niiko Burkina il
y a des comités de pilotage commun et on
est un peu comme des sous-traitants
là-bas regardez enfin pour simplifier ça
c'est l'immunité évoquée par le chef de
l'État mais ça veut dire que ça change
radicalement complètement et l'armée
nigérienne qui s'est doté depuis le
président Bazoom qui a multiplié par 3
ces effectifs et qui va encore par deux
c'est à dire qu'en disant ils vont être
multipliés par 6 et bien là on voit
qu'il y a une capacité d'intervention
beaucoup plus forte des Nigériens une
meilleure prise en compte des capacités
stratégiques et derrière les Français
qui viennent en renfort et donc ça c'est
très différent de ce qui s'est fait et
au Mali et au Burkina et le plus
difficile pour les Français ça va être
effectivement de se mettre dans une
posture dans une attitude au service de
ce qui n'est pas depuis depuis la
colonisation qui n'est pas l'attitude
principale des français en Afrique et ça
ça un changement je vous rejoins
là-dessus je répondais juste à la
question des académies mais d'un point
de vue opérationnel je vous rejoins à
100% et vous faites référence à l'époque
de la colonisation au Gabon le chef de
l'État Emmanuel Macron a même été
jusqu'à annoncé la fin de la France
Afrique alors c'est vrai que Jacques
Chirac Nicolas Sarkozy François Hollande
aussi avait annoncé la fin de la France
Afrique est-ce qu'il faut y croire j'ai
du mal à y croire moi mais attendant
pourquoi pas sur l'aspect opérationnel
effectivement au niveau en tout cas
militaire on a on a quand même appris
d'un certain nombre d'erreurs qui
avaient été commise au Mali il faut il
faut le reconnaître moi là où je suis
dubitatif c'est que dans son discours
Emmanuel Macron en intervalle de 30
secondes il a expliqué qu'il fallait
être moins visible les forces armées
devaient être moins visibles et en même
temps il a expliqué qu'il fallait être
plus visible dans le champ
informationnel donc j'attends de voir
qu'est-ce que cela donne sur le champ
informationnel moi ce que je sais c'est
qu'au niveau des populations notamment
ça Éliane globalement West africaine
c'est qu'il y a un rejet assez massif de
cette présence militaire française
aujourd'hui c'est le marqueur principal
avec un autre marqueur qui est celui du
franc CFA de rejet de la politique
française sur le continent africain
depuis les années de l'ancienne
puissance coloniale et
c'est très important quand même cette
présence parce que aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus faire les choses sans prendre
en compte les opinions publiques et les
opinions publiques aujourd'hui sont très
remontées dans cette pays pour le
président Bazoom au Niger c'est très
difficile d'assumer cette coopération
avec la France parce que on voit bien
que dans la jeunesse notamment il y a un
rejet total de la France dans son
discours lire total
d'une partie d'une partie de la jeunesse
très importante
et en fait dans son discours certains
attendaient peut-être l'annonce de
fermeture de base pas toutes mais
certaines bon il y a eu aucune fermeture
de base qui a été annoncée donc moi
j'attends de voir quelle forme va
prendre ce nouveau dispositif j'ai
tendance à être un peu dubitatif par
rapport à un éventuel vraiment
changement de paradigme certains ont été
jusqu'à dire qu'avec ce discours on
passait de la France gendarme de
l'Afrique aussi à la France business
autrement dit l'idée c'était peut-être
de décélérer un petit peu de
d'apparaître moins en première ligne sur
le plan militaire mais de reconquérir
des pas marché il est temps parce que
les parts de marché de la France en
Afrique c'est 4% du marché celle des
chinois c'est aujourd'hui 18% pour ne
parler que des chinois c'est une
interprétation qui vous paraît assez
juste aussi dans ce qui a été le
discours du chef de l'État et sa tournée
qui a juste suivi en Afrique centrale
oui bien sûr il y a cet élément
économique mais là aussi on nous annonce
une grande nouveauté c'est quelque chose
qui a été répété de manière récurrente
par les autorités exécutives et
diplomatiques successives depuis une
trentaine d'années notamment l'ouverture
hors des pays du ce qu'on appelle le
chant à savoir les pays francophones
donc une ouverture économique une
conquête des marchés en Afrique
anglophone
on n'a pas véritablement l'impression
que cela a changé la perception que
donne la France de sa présence sur le
continent d'une manière générale à mon
avis la France de trop embrassée en
parlant d'être présente dans le domaine
culturel dans le domaine sportif dans le
domaine économique dans le domaine
militaire dans le domaine diplomatique
la plupart des autres partenaires parce
que les États africains aujourd'hui
multiplient les partenaires ont des
champs d'investissement extrêmement
précis extrêmement bien identifié 30
secondes votre point de vue je pense que
les contre la France oui comme quantité
colonial et post colonial mais pas avec
les Français moi je continue à parler
avec les mêmes personnes au Mali avec
qu'avant il y a pas de différence donc
moi ce qu'on me dit en Afrique on me dit
on veut on veut la France mais on la
veut autrement et c'est autrement qu'il
faut définir il faut du froid du temps
pour cela le principal souci à mon avis
c'est qu'on a pas les acteurs on n'a pas
les chefs d'entreprise on n'a pas les
mouvements associatifs qui connaissent
l'Afrique et qui vont investir l'Afrique
dans leur champ le problème principal
c'est celui-ci c'est que on manque et de
connaissance fine du terrain et
d'acteurs qui vont aller s'investir
là-bas et on verra si pourtant on a des
millions de binationaux qui ne demandent
qu'à jouer la relation France-Afrique ne
favorise pas suffisamment les stratégies
vers les binationaux qui sont
populations tout à fait apte et qui ont
envie de jouer leur deux pays d'origine
et on verra ainsi cette autrement
ces fameux solutions que vous évoquez
figurant dans évidemment dans le rapport
de votre mission parlementaire que vous
êtes en train
de mettre en place et vous nous avez
annoncé que les conclusions de cette
mission devrait être connue si tout va
bien en septembre prochain un grand
merci vraiment à tous les trois l'avoir
participé à cette émission des Badoc
aujourd'hui vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter merci
également à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumée à préparer cette émission
et je vous donne bien sûr rendez-vous
pour un prochain débat doc ça sera avec
son documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]